I want to pull up this story here this
is from the recount
Minneapolis judge sentenced Tau Tau a
former police officer who held back
bystanders as other officers pinned
George Floyd to the ground to four years
and nine months in State Prison
I look at this judge and I see a deeply
deeply evil individual this cop Tau Tau
probably pronouncing his name wrong
because it's some Nuance to this to the
name it's t-o-u-t-h-a-o he's 37 years
old he's a nine-year veteran of the
force he arrives on scene and all he did
was hold back bystanders and I don't
believe he could even see what was going
on or knew what was going on he's gotten
I think three years in prison at the
federal level and now just about five
more years at the state level wow this
is it if you go against the regime or
actually if you accidentally go go
against them they just destroy your life
you know this this racialism I think I
think of it like this black hole theory
of of politics and Justice and such it's
like racialism
politics you know it's like a black hole
and and it distorts everything around it
including the justice system and I I
don't see how fee how you know you know
I know how we're all supposed to think
about the Floyd verdicts but I don't see
how anyone could look at those Floyd
verdicts and think well that was Justice
in the sense that the jury operated
honestly and dispassionately without
pressure again of violence and we forget
about that part of this scenario and
just kind of what people understood
about Floyd's uh situation at the time
and the obvious and the training that
the police officers had that they
seemingly were trying to follow you know
I didn't I didn't support the verdict it
was you know you don't want to see
someone die unnecessarily but certainly
in my my view was it it wasn't murder or
anything close to it here's where I go
crazy this TaoTao gentleman he was
basically responsible for holding back
the crowd while these other officers
kneeled on him and sure maybe he didn't
do everything perfect and maybe
ultimately he could have prevented it I
don't know what what drives me crazy is
that this guy even though he's not
really culpable I think if you're
evaluating this fairly he's not truly
culpable for the passing of George Floyd
but he's gonna do maybe eight years but
then you have the the murderer of Daniel
shaver in Arizona which if you watch
that video it's one of the most
egregious cop killings that has ever
transpired in American history as far as
I'm concerned and he walks free better
than that he also gets a a pension for
his psychological damage from that's
what he did this is the guy who was told
to crawl on the ground yes Simon Says
execution yeah yeah I don't know much
about that when did this there was a guy
in a hotel room and he had a pellet gun
because he was a pest exterminator
someone called into the police and said
they saw someone with a gun so these
Cops show up scream at him with rifles
pointed saying on the ground put your
hands up put your hands down crawl
toward me crawl towards me not put your
hands up now crawl towards me to put
your hands up when the guy's Pants start
falling down and he pulls them up the
cops unloads on him he was he was drunk
he had his shirt off and he was wearing
sweatpants at the time he was in a hotel
and they had him on his knees and so as
he's crawling towards them with his
hands up his the his knees are dragging
and pulling his pants down his sweats
down so he goes and he reaches down to
pull them up and while crying yeah yeah
terrified he was horrified yeah this
damn this uh George Floyd thing I think
it's another example of how technocracy
is leading us to to communism because
what happens is the media chooses what
Clips get shared over and over and over
again and what can't be shared I tried
to talk about the family the media you
mean we'll say social media algorithms
meta for instance censored my posts
trying to talk about the fentanyl in his
system the guy was doing an eight ball
or what a speedball what's the rules it
takes behind the wheel of a car so like
the media that got pushed out was the
few minutes that he can't breathe I
can't breathe I can't breathe people go
crazy and then the the cops the job of
the law enforcement is like protect the
peace they don't care about who's guilty
or sent they don't want riots
this this Tau Tau is going to prison
because they just want to avoid more
social breakdown that means understand
this if you live in a city like
Minneapolis if you live in a city like
Portland OR Seattle and you are a victim
of violent crime from the likes of a
far-left extremist or even just a
run-of-male criminal
you could be the victim and there is no
out for you you fight back you go to
jail you try and stop the criminals you
go to jail just like the guys in the
Ahmed Aubry case you cower in the corner
of your house as people scream outside
the cops go into your home and they
arrest you that's what we've been seeing
happen
and of course it's the black community
of Indianapolis who suffer the most here
uh because the police have been
decimated there uh they they have
virtual no protection from the police
anymore and so you know now we're
veering towards Anarchy in our major
cities uh as a result of the soft on
crime policies resulting or where we're
not resulting from where the Floyd
killing was used as an excuse to advance
this radical agenda
of decriminalization of everything they
don't believe in putting anyone in
prison for any reason yeah you know it's
not they just don't oppose the death
penalty they don't want anyone and when
you think the whole system's corrupt all
jails are corrupt and no one should go
to them one this is a radical approach
that's get getting people killed right
now as we speak well one one minor
clarification it really is specifically
dictionary definition anarchod tyranny
because not only are they not enforcing
violent crime laws but they also
disarmed the people so they can't even
defend themselves so on both ends of it
you're basically just set up to be a
victim and then that's is that because
from the leader's perspective if you
have one class violating another class
and then the other class decides to
fight back now you've got two classes of
villains and you can arrest them all the
criminals destabilize the system and
keep people in a state of constant fear
and Chaos unable to take any actions
against the power structure
so long as there are people at the
bottom fighting each other
the people in power are because we need
Grassroots movements to control the the
top that's the whole point of the United
States is the people control the
government if the people are fighting
each other they're not going to be able
to rein in that power structure I'm just
concerned like what Clint was saying
that the ship has sailed uh and the
Empire is now in the Congress I think
like throughout history
what we have seen and what we've seen in
our media depicting potentialities of
revolution
I'm reminded of the scene from V for
Vendetta where the narrow the inspector
is narrating he says eventually someone
does something stupid it then shows the
police officer the finger man shoot the
little girl wearing the mask and then
all the locals just surround him with
baseball bats pipes and crowbars and
then the camera pans up and the
assumption is they beat him to death
when you get to a point where police
officers are going to prison for
literally doing nothing when you've got
stories of people who on January 6 were
walking around confused I I learned this
story just recently of a woman who I met
and she said that it was a few hours
after the capital had been breached they
were walking around DC and they walked
to the Capitol with nothing going on
there's no people there's like people
walking around there's no cops there's
no barricades no one saying anything
they walked up looking around and then
left four misdemeanor charges a year and
a half in jail I'm saying we should have
her on the show I don't know how prudent
is to have someone on the show it's
facing January six charges but that
story needs to be well an interview
perhaps but the question is at what
point do regular people say there isn't
a justice system and I want to clarify
this the reason why the founding fathers
thought innocent until proven guilty was
so important was not because they like
you partly because they like you and
they're good Christians God-fearing
people who believed in individuality and
right but no no no there was something
greater the founding fathers talked
about if people believe that that if no
matter what they do the government will
punish or imprison them then they have
no incentive to be law-abiding citizens
if a criminal is treated all the same as
an innocent person then screw it but if
the system says we protect you if you're
innocent then there is every incentive
for the individual to be an innocent
person knowing that we'll fight on your
behalf but that's changing now with what
this judge has done with what they're
doing in January 6 they're telling the
people no matter what you do we will
punish you no matter if you're innocent
confused ignorant or otherwise if you're
at your house in Milwaukee and BLM shows
up screaming and threatening you a group
that had previously set fire to a house
twice the cops will come into your home
and arrest do that actually happened
FairPoint the guy living in the house
brandished a shotgun through the window
not out the window but up to the glass
of his window he showed the people
protesting he was armed so the police
came went into his house and arrested
him and the BLM activists cheered for it
these are people who had previously been
at a house that they set on fire twice
yeah yeah the guy the guy that got
arrested his house was set on fire okay
BLM shows up a BLM affiliate activists
essentially formed a mob showed up to a
house where they believed two girls had
been illegally held it was not true they
set fire to the house the fire
department puts the fire out they leave
the mob sets fire again fire department
puts a fire out that same group similar
group organized by similar people show
up to the house of a guy who had
criticize black lives matter screaming
and protesting in front of his home
in front of his window he branded as a
shotgun in his own house
they call the police a brandished a
weapon the cops walk up to his house and
arrest him from in his own home well it
is easier to arrest you the target of
the mob than it is to deal with a riot
yeah
I was watching uh these comments some of
them and you know when we talk about
this stuff I get this is the black pill
I can take it I don't necessarily get
black build I can handle a little bit of
it
I'm like what is a I'm wargaming this
where's it go Revolution an upheaval and
an overturning of the US government to
something that will never be nearly as
good as U.S government we have it so
good right now yeah this is where are
you gonna say that I think I think our
Republic is tottering again I think
you know if Trump is jailed and is
unable to to campaign or effectively has
the election turned against them because
of this jailing uh you know there's not
going to be riots there's not going to
be Mass demonstrations it's just going
to be concern and you know the
Constitution will have been left behind
we'll be in a post-constitutional system
where uh American citizens who are on
the wrong side of the democratic party
and this I don't like to get partisan
but it's true this is a Democratic party
using the justice department the jail
their political opponents and there are
a lot of Americans who aren't going to
you know participate in the system our
political system if they fear that
they're going to get jailed I think one
of the
ugly undersides of the indictment of
trump is is Smith's targeting of
citizens in the several States who were
best they understood under the law
trying to challenge an election and in a
way that had been done many times before
it could seemingly comply with federal
state and constitutional law and he
suggested they were engaged in criminal
conspiracy so that's a signal don't
don't don't challenge any elections that
we're we're we've won so to speak
otherwise you'll get jailed but now some
people are going to say no and they will
continue to but a lot will will will
stay out of the stay out of the game
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time